des milliers d'arméniens de france et
leurs soutiens se sont regroupés
aujourd'hui près de l'ambassade de
turquie à paris dans le 16ème
arrondissement
il s'était déjà mobilisé la veille à
bruxelles ils étaient 5000 est
aujourd'hui dans le même temps il se
trouvait à marseille est également à
nice ils protestaient contre bac oui
contre ankara pourquoi la turquie bien
parce que le pays est accusé de soutenir
les forces d'azerbaïdjan les soutenir
militairement mais également en envoyant
des djihadistes syriens alors les
manifestants aujourd'hui on prononçait
des slogans contraire doan et
l'expansionnisme turc il ya eu des
prises de paroles également de diverses
personnalités
je vous propose de les écouter nous
voulons tout simplement l'arrêt des
combats
enfin la barre et que
la france la france le président de la
république française
emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
reconnaissent l'indépendance du radar à
son juste titre aux arméniens et que la
paix revienne
voilà c'est tout c'est une honte que ce
soit l'europe l'otan la france les pays
de l'accord de minsk c'est à dire les
états unis la russie et la france ne
fasse rien face à la destruction
programmée du haut karabagh surtout pour
ce qui est de la france
la france a déjà lâché les arméniens
pendant la guerre de s'initier et
l'arménie occidentale qu'occupe et yoann
parce que le traité de sèvres accordent
ces régions aux arméniens avec la
sentence du président wilson
donc c'est une occasion en or pour la
france de rattraper cette erreur
historique
la france aujourd'hui est en tête de ce
combat pour bloquer la turquie mais la
france est isolée
le problème c'est que l'europe continue
toujours comme d'habitude sa politique
ambiguë avec la turquie
l'europe n'a pas à continuer à négocier
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'union
européenne et continue à donner un
milliard d'euros tous les ans à la
turquie dans le cadre de cette
couverture là il n'y a pas de sanctions
internationales il n'ya pas de blocus
international
les arméniens de france appelle la
communauté internationale à se mobiliser
ainsi que la france pour que les combats
cessent au plus vite dans le
haut-karabagh ils prévoient d'autres
actions dans les jours qui viennent